good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the overview and scrutiny committee I
will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement there are no
plan to fire drills so if the alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via your nearest fire
exit please use if the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is the island
outside the main entrance to this
building please do not delay in your
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building till given permission to do so
by Council staff please know that the
meeting will be live streamed please
switch off mobile phones which I can
hear already
um or turn them to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer era
[Music]
okay
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for show of hands four then
against recommendations and we'll also
ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
a gender item one apologies for absence
we've received apologies from councilor
Mrs Mason and councilor Mr E and Mason
are there any other apologies please
members
thank you
the gender item two there are no
substitute members agenda item three
non-members attending councilor Mrs
Julie Gooding and
and councilor Mr Linden
the gender item of four minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of April 2023
for those who were here are the minutes
agree with please members
agreed thank you
a gender item five to do to receive
Declarations of Interest members are
there any Declarations of Interest
decorations with them
the general item six the cost of living
report members I would like to welcome
Bash from Mahmoud but correctly thank
you of active Essex Victoria marzuki
from revs Rayleigh and Rochford
Association voluntary services and Julie
Salford in Scott Williamson who we've
met before from the mega Center who have
kindly agreed to join the meeting this
evening and welcome to counselor
um Mrs Julie goodin lead member for
leisure tourism and well-being who is
also present for this item
thank you
members I would like to now invite Tracy
Lilly director of the community in
health to introduce the report she will
be assisted by Kelly Redstone
Partnerships officer and we're also hear
from our guests you are of course
welcome to ask the lead member officers
and guest questions during the debate of
this item
thank you Tracy
thank you chair I don't intend to say
too much I know shock horror we've got
some really great Partners here this
evening and like I've said around the
the response that the council gives to
the cost of living it's not what we can
do it's about us supporting and
coordinating and so I'm posting to our
excellent partners that we have so I'm
hope well I'm confident actually I'm not
hoping I'm confident that after the
presentations that you'll have this
evening you may have some questions but
you'll see just the great work that
continues to happen in support of those
suffering the cost of living crisis
good evening
thank you for allowing us to come
tonight to present the cost of living
um as Tracy says so I'm fully support
the fact that these partners are
actually what makes this plan work so
the council's function
um back last year when we look to this
as one tea was to facilitate coordinate
assign post individuals and
organizations to information where's the
police is provided
um it was really important for us that
we understood that we weren't
necessarily the right people to provide
that direct support that we had lots and
lots of organizations and and support
across the partnership across the
district where they were much better
placed to provide that support but we
came together as a group we looked at
the areas that we needed to to provide
support to Residents businesses staff
and anyone else that was facing
difficulties due to cost of living so we
offered support through the website with
bills and money support with food and
Essentials support for well-being
support to go green support for
businesses and support with work
council's website which is up there in
shared making League provides a huge
amount of information and it's updated
regularly with information that we
receive from County Council National
information guidance and good practice
as well as the Fantastic updated
information from partners
we came together last year as a
collaborative working group so the
formation of the action plan around cost
of living wasn't just Council focus it
was around the work that we do together
the working group came together to
understand and George given the support
that's currently available and what
you'll see in the presentations that are
forthcoming is is how some of that
support has been delivered and some of
the data that sits behind what was
delivered so what it tells us
um
as an officer what we did initially was
a group of officers we tried to
understand what data it was that we held
so in previous meetings in the executive
seen some earlier Renditions of the
dashboard
the dashboard has grown and changed
according to the way that we can Harvest
that data from those Partners so I'll
move on to that in a minute we've also
worked in other ways so our Commons has
been essential and our common team have
been fantastic in pushing out that
Central website page to make sure that
people can update access to updated
information and actually we know that
people are clicking on it more than once
and again you'll see that information on
the dashboard
our partners here today we'll talk about
some of the other schools that's been
given some of the food support the warm
halves and and the support with vouchers
and um
household bills so I'll cover some of
that under the citizens advice which I'm
going to present to you this evening on
behalf of Cafe kentish and then some of
it will be covered by The Hub update
I'd like to ask you just to take the
time to listen to the presentation is 48
slides long I promise you it's not going
to be that boring and just hold your
questions to ask as a panel at the end
councilworld Council award yeah can I
ask that this be turned off because it's
buzzing like mad and it's very
disturbing thank you thank you
but just pause Kelly while that's been
sorted thank you
thank you
um so the development
collaboratively is the working group we
came up with the action plan the action
plan is something that is cancerous I'm
sure you've seen many times so isn't
part of this presentation that is
available to you I want to remind you
that the action plan was for 22-23
we're out of that period now we're now
at a stage where we're looking at the
data we're working collaboratively we'll
be planning the future meetings to look
at what the action plan should look like
for 23 24. and we will be sharing that
with you and we will obviously be
gathering
um engagement and consultation with
counselors around the data that we
provide in the action plan that produces
what we know is that the action plan is
going to be simpler
easier to to digest and will be
supported by some strong data which
wasn't the position that we was in last
year when we needed to respond quickly
to the cost of living
so I'll move on to the dashboard
as I say it's changed
over the months the first dashboard was
designed for December and released in
January and as we've gathered data you
can now see what we was aiming for with
the dashboard which is over time the
measurements of those needs what
additional pressures was it put in on
the services that we provided so in
terms of support from the council in
terms of homelessness and those at risk
of homelessness actually the numbers
haven't changed much from previous year
this is really interesting
but not surprising given that we've been
through two years of covered previously
and we had a lot of issues and a lot of
time to prepare around homelessness so I
think we can congratulate the uh the
housing team on the success of
supporting those in need and for them
not to get to the stage where they're
homeless
um in terms of the council tax reduction
screen scheme and the discretionary
housing payments again from the previous
year there was not a large upturn so
from 22 to 23 I'm sorry 21 to 22 to 22
to 23 the figures are not that much
different
uh in terms of cost of relate cost of
living relate calls received by uh
customer services we asked them to
recall those separately customer
services have been providing web page
details and supporting residents where
needed to access that information
they've been really minimal to the point
that actually last month in May
the last month of recording there were
none related to cost of living
in terms of support from our partners
um the numbers were higher because we
know that they were the right the right
organizations in the right place to
provide that support
so from December
going into January and into February the
number of people seeking support in
crisis
the number of people people seeking
support for warm hubs and the number of
people seeking support for food banks
has increased over that time
what's interesting is that we know that
through the partnership work with the
Hub at the mega Center that we've put
forward that they are a really good
first pool of call because they can
enable all of our residents to access
citizens advice to access rough services
to access the half program and the half
term program it's it's been really
fantastic we also know that the mega
Center the Harvard Medical Center has
developed its relationship with the food
bank and that's now provided as a
service out of the center and that means
that we know what's coming in what those
crises are and some of the content so we
know that on top of that on top of
supporting people through the food bank
there's been additional projects which
Julian Scott will come on and talk to
you about later which has been really
effective where they've requested money
from outside they've got they've put in
bids for funding and been successful
but I will not steal their Thunder
in terms of communication what we know
is that
our comms team have put out the
information really regularly and has
been absolutely fantastic in doing that
we know that people are clicking onto
the social media across all forums and
that we are getting some clicks through
to the site
what's amazing about the figures if you
look at the total reach is that it's
increased year month on month apologies
it should go from December at the top
down to May at the bottom there I'll um
I'll update that before I send that
dashboard
and it's he's increasing people are
looking for this information so I find
something useful that the information
centers on the council web pages
but then
filled us out to the relevant
organizations for the right help
the last figure that I put in here is is
from the half program which
um will be your last presentation of the
evening
active Essex have really come to the
Forefront in determining what might be
needed by those most vulnerable in our
young people and half program as you'll
see has had such an impact over the last
couple of years but particularly when
applied to cost of living and it's a
reminder that the work that we do every
day is part of cost of living what you
hear about tonight is not lots of new
responses it's the responses that
partners are there to give we're just
coordinating the information it's been a
real journey a real learning experience
and I hope that you'll give our partners
some some real Accolade this evening for
for what they've achieved
so that's it from the council what I'll
do is I'll move on
and apologies from Kathy kentish tonight
Kathy couldn't make it she's gone off on
holiday and left us for a foreign land
so
if I just flick back say previously on
the cost of living under support from
Partners I would have pushed the figures
together for that I got from citizens
advice and you'd have known about people
in crisis and how many people it was
just numbers
what Kathy and citizens advice South
assets have been able to do is to really
drill down into those key statistics so
now what they provide for us and what
we've got for every month since January
is these um sheets so these started to
come around in March and I was hoping to
bring them to April executive but
couldn't quite crunch it down at that
time so this is probably the first time
you're seeing them as it is it talks
about
and the number of clients each month and
it talks about the issues and the
activities so if you go over to the
issues you can see there the benefits is
it's massive you know again when we're
talking about cost of living we know
that it's affecting everybody but those
that are actually seeking support are
those that are most vulnerable and as
you look at the figures from January
through to Matty you'll see that
reflected in the citizens advice Figures
it's also interesting it gives you kind
of the top benefit issues the top debt
issues uh age ranges Kelly I'm just
gonna have to interrupt you sorry
Council award
thank you chairman
um
it would have been helpful if we'd have
had
um you know some something in front of
us even if it had been sent to us so we
could have seen it because I can't see
your talking of things but I really
don't understand what you're talking
about
I mean if you're referring to that can't
see anything no
um I have to concur with Council award
um I had actually the other report to be
circulated before tonight
apologies the sides have taken some time
to get the partnership information
together the slide pack is 48 46 slides
long I what I've spoken to
um tonight is that they'll come out in
the members pack this week I need to
upload to them I can't send it as an
email it's too big
but I am happy to share it and I'll put
my email address in there so you can ask
any direct questions about any of the
data that's in the pack
um members
um are you in agreement that we just
have the top line data tonight and leave
the slides because I'm struggling and
I'm just here and can't read them
once we get through the citizens advice
sites they're actually a little less
so these are data slides and that is is
the issue with all data it's never
simple
so as I say so if you go through I'll
get this sent out to you you'll see this
January's February's March is aprils and
Mays this gives us a fair indication of
what people are applying for what
support they need what age they are
um and I will provide my email address
I'm happy to take any questions that
anyone has about the data from citizens
advice what it does show us and what was
interesting when I spoke to Kathy and
Sue Murray is that again the figures for
April or May 2023
are fairly representative of the figures
for May the same quarter last year 21
22. so although the pressure is higher
and some of the issues are different
actually the case load the workload is
pretty similar so actually what we're
finding is maybe it's different people
that are accessing citizens advice at
the moment it might be more intuitive
information so people are not waiting
until they get to the point where
they're in debt crisis they are
accessing information at an earlier
stage and you'll see the differentiation
in the figures as you go through
so that is the information from citizen
virus if there is any questions on the
side so please do let me know I'm more
than happy to answer any questions
related to data what I'll do now is I'll
pass you over to Victoria oh no sorry to
Julie or Scott first
to Scott
um if you just give me the nod when you
want me to change slides okay great
thank you good evening to you all uh
lovely to see you again in a much more
relaxed environment so lovely to be with
you
um so let me just do the front page and
then I'll hand over to
um my variable assistant to let you know
all the information and this is I want
to start with this um sorry you might
not be able to do the fingers on the
infection on the left but you will be on
the right
um just to say that two years ago in the
hub we together with yourselves and
counselors if you remember in the mega
Center all on individual chairs and sat
two and a half three meters away from
each other we started the community Hub
um to help work in our community to help
the most vulnerable
what I'd like to inform you
um is again just a reminder that it's
your Hub we facilitate it on your behalf
to help people in our community but
um we have meetings both with um Essex
but also with national government and
you'll be pleased to know I hope that
this is one of the only Community hubs
that is still in existence since the
pandemic started and so you can go from
up and down the whole country and see a
community Hub working in this way we've
got over 32 Partners now
um it's still working it's still growing
it's still achieves what it needs to
achieve and by the grace of God it still
gets enough funding to do that and so
actually when we go to well I go to
meetings nationally
um and and also Essex wide
um it's the only one that's still going
so um we've been asked by Essex to model
this in another three locations in Essex
which we've said no to currently because
we want to focus our attention here in
Rochester where we live and where we've
had a heart for the community over the
last 27 years but I just wanted to say
that to you for two reasons one just to
inform you and secondly hopefully to
just uh just to for you to realize and
and hopefully you know pride is an awful
thing at times if it's not put in the
right context but in the right context
it's good to be proud of what we do and
actually with the help of Kelly who's
been an absolutely wonderful asset all
the way through it and and some
wonderful counselors and certainly the
reason most right at the start
um this this Hub thing is just going
well Julie will tell you what we've done
on cost of living but in terms of how
the Hub is growing
um every single week is expanding every
single week it's helping more and more
people uh in our community and every
single week is having an impact and
every single week we're getting
attention from other people nationally
who are asking us you know how do we
make this work and this is the closing
I'll pass over to to um to Julie I think
the reason it works is because there's
no how do I say it we work together you
know there's no arrogancy there's no
Pretend We're just we work together for
the best interest of our community the
question of myself and Julie ask every
single week in the senior management
meeting with regards to our Hub staff is
simply this how can we make the
environment which our residents live in
this week a better place
and then the answer of the answers of
that is what we go away and try and
Achieve on your behalf
um so so thank you for the way that you
support it if you don't know anything
about it well
do come and have coffee
um because you probably should know
about it because it's at your community
Hub
um do come and talk to us we'd love to
tell you more about it but I'll let my
colleague talk to you about how we've
helped with the cost of living and
support thank you hello young lady
thank you
foreign
yeah thank you Scott and good evening
everybody
um yeah as Scott said the Hub is is your
community Hub
um and we believe that we are stronger
together
um stronger as a partnership we can do
more to support our residents um
together
um we want to care for our community we
want to connect them and make them more
resilient which is which is what we aim
to do and which is what I think we do do
so it's really great
um our strength is our connections with
each other as Community Partners and our
connections with our residents
um we listen to our community we respond
when the need arises such as a pandemic
a couple of years ago and latterly and
currently because it is still going on
the cost of living crisis
residents are in a lot of cases having
to make a decision do I heat my home or
do I eat do I buy food for my children
and that is a dreadful decision for any
family or any want to have to make
we get referrals from lots of different
places for instance Essex child and
family wellbeing service so that's the
family hubs Peabody who support around
the cost of living and housing and
benefits schools social Care Family
Solutions NHS Partners including School
nurses Health visitors and GPS the
department for work and pensions we get
so many referrals from Rayleigh job
center in particular United in kind
churches our own charity team so our
family workers our youth workers our
community workers who are working
directly with the families and residents
that need the support
self-referrals as well people that have
heard what we do what we can offer
people ringing up and saying I don't
know what to do I've got you know I'm
struggling and I don't know where to
turn referrals from residents quite
often we see on Facebook I'm struggling
for food I'm struggling to pay my bills
who can I turn to and people sign post
them to the Hub at the make Center
um so we do respond to those questions
and you can see by that little chart on
there that over the last
um year we've been looking between well
it's six months January to June not 2023
um 234 food Parcels were provided by The
Hub through our partner hope Works who
provide the food support
um 75 of those were for residents in
Rochford District
um so it's it's a big chunk of our
referrals that come from our district
together
and the cost of living crisis affects us
all as the pandemic affected us all in
different ways we're all conscious of
the fact that bills are going up that
food prices are going up that families
can't afford to buy the things they need
for their children can't afford to give
them school uniform it is affecting
every single one of us whatever our
situation we're all noticing that
difference
so the next slide
um is a little graph
um just to show the comparison
um between the food Parcels that were
given out from September to June in 2021
compared to 22 to 23. so the blue line
at the bottom is is the previous year so
that stayed fairly steady as you can see
the orange line on top shows the
increase this year with the the cost
cost of living crisis so when I saw this
I thought that really does show it quite
clearly
um the difference in in the struggles
that people are experiencing this year
so moving on to the next slide in
addition to the food Parcels that we
give out through hopeworks to our
partner we've had some funding this year
from the Essex Association of local
councils we had three thousand pounds
for food support
and we were able to give residents
vouchers we bought vouchers from
different supermarkets so the
supermarkets that were locally in 25
pounds denominations so they were able
to go and buy fresh things to complement
their food Parcels that they were given
they were able to go and buy nappies
baby milk all those sort of things that
maybe aren't necessarily part of a
standard food parcel but still things
that people are essential things
depending on the family makeup we were
able to give more than one voucher we
were able to support people over a
period of time
so the community was so grateful to be
able to have that benefit and to be able
to buy what they needed in total those
vouchers were able to support 103
families with 278 people in total
supported with that
the cost of living crisis isn't going to
go away it's with us for the foreseeable
future so we need to continue to think
about what we can do to support our
community
we are working closely with our
community partners with Rochford Council
we there was a health and wellbeing
event held in March that was all around
the cost of living which was an amazing
event is so well attended by partners by
residents and the support that was able
to be offered through that event was was
incredible we were working now to think
about another event in in the Autumn but
working with Community Partners such as
United inclined we were able to provide
warm bags for residents so scarves hats
gloves soup mugs soup tea coffee
vouchers
um slow cookers all kinds of things we
work closely with active ethics this
summer for the holidays which is a
blessing and a challenge for a lot of
families it's lovely to have you know
the time off but at the same time
families are struggling to feed their
children through those holidays because
they might get free School meals and
children seem to change in the holidays
they're constantly hungry so you always
need to have a full fridge or a full
cupboard but we're working closely with
active Essex with the half program so
we're able to provide 500 places for
children that are on free School meals
to come along to the mega Center for a
holiday club to have food to have
activities to have some fun and take the
pressure off the parents a little bit as
well so it's a benefit the children and
the parents
um
we are looking to the Future as I say
we're about to start a weekly drop-in at
the mega Center
um from Peabody
um so there'll be a presence in the mega
Center for anybody to come along to to
chat to
um we have had a representative from the
job center attend at the mega Center
once a week for a year or so
um he's a troubled families employment
advisor so he can support families make
sure they're getting all the benefits
they're entitled to help them with job
search help them with CVS help them with
all kinds of things
um citizens advice come along and have
drop-ins there from time to time United
in kind run I think it's two sessions a
week there so it's not just about having
that warm space which was so beneficial
over the winter because we were a warm
bank or a warm space working with the
community but United in kindron there
hugging a shrug project their knitting
group which not only is somewhere for
people to go to get out of the cold over
the winter but it cuts through the
isolation and loneliness and that people
are feeling as well so they can come
along and meet with others active Essex
the library service Essex child with
family wellbeing service the NHS
worrying talks at the moment working
with Victoria to think about a Community
Supermarket for our district our
district is is quite unique it's it's
wonderful but it's huge and we've got
our pockets of residents we've got
Rayleigh we've got Rochford we've got
Hockley holbridge we've got all those
areas but we've also got some Villages
you know thinking about great wakering
and canuden and all those little areas
where residents live but haven't got
Supermarket haven't got somewhere where
they can go and buy reasonably priced
food and stuff
um Community supermarkets or that bridge
between having a food parcel and having
that support to going shopping at Asda
or Tesco's or Sainsbury's is somewhere
where people can go to get some
reasonably priced food
um but because of the makeup of our
district because we're such a big
geographical area we're looking at a
mobile provision so a supermarket that
can travel around and be a presence in a
church hall or in a library or in a
school or wherever we decide that is a
good place and we're looking for funding
to be able to develop that
and we just want to continue to listen
to respond to our residents and to step
up when there's need and hopefully help
with that
um and my last slide is really just some
comments from some residents I won't
read them out because you will be sent
them but it's comments from people that
have said Thank you have said I don't
know where I'd be without you
um and one person said to me I'm usually
the person who offers the help now I'm
the person who's having to ask for help
and that feels very strange
um but we are all in this together we
are all experiencing the cost of living
crisis whatever our situations so it's
about saying we do want to help and we
understand and we will continue to help
thank you
you can miss that slide Kelly sorry it's
okay right now thank you very much
everyone it's really great to be able to
come and share
um some of the support that ravs gave to
the community
um
we were pleased to be oh be given five
thousand pound from Russia District
Council to support warm spaces which was
a national initiative started or spoken
about by the delightful Martin Lewis and
um we
open we were able to fund 10 warm spaces
uh but actually 19 opened in all
throughout the district they were
supported mainly by faith groups
um they opened their warm space not as
an additional project but they sort of
tagged it on to something they were
already running
um it wasn't just about people coming to
a warm space because it was cheaper than
heating their own home it was also being
able to connect them with services that
they probably weren't aware of being
able to connect them with people and
reducing uh isolation and loneliness
um
I'll be honest was the uptake great no
it wasn't
um I don't think
um that although the initiative was very
good that people really didn't want to
leave the warmth of their own home get
on a bus walk down the road to somewhere
else and then go home and reheat their
home again so
you know there's loads of positive work
we have to try things we don't get it
right all the time
um but the people that did attend it
made a difference to their winter and
our belief is if we helped one person it
was one person that wasn't lonely and
one person that wasn't cold and one
person that wasn't hungry sorry
um the
on the next slide I'll show you the
poster but most of the the counselors
were sharing the poster so you'll know
exactly what it looks like
um we the posts on Facebook were shared
around two and a half thousand times a
month but December's post about warm
spaces was shared three thousand times
um
all the warm spaces offered free
refreshments and all of the warm spaces
were operated by volunteers there was no
salaried cost and I think you know that
is a real dedication to this district
and our community that people stepped up
when they were you know they were
probably worrying about heating their
own homes but they stepped up to help
others and I I think that needs
recognizing
um
all of the warm spaces except Mark's
hall closed at the end of March and most
of them opened in October
um and Saint Mark's Hall continued to
operate twice a week up until the end of
May
um the team at Hockley Methodist Church
realized that there is a need for
Community Support in their area beyond
the warm space and they are currently
working on a project to open one
afternoon a week and they're looking a
variety of speakers supported by ravs
I'm posting them to contacts
um the warm spaces didn't deliver value
for money and although valuable as I
said to those that attend I feel there
is a more successful way to support a
residents where we go to them they don't
come to us and I think that is the
future of warm space or winter support
under cost of living in 23 24. it's okay
to sit here and look back on what we've
done but I also think it's important to
share with you some of the thinking
about what we can deliver going forward
that means that we are seen as a
responsive reactive
Partners who are going to give our
residents value for money
um you have all seen this wonderful
poster it was it was shared wide it was
updated I think I have to recognize my
member of Staff Lindsay who was on it
all the time updating it and and
literally making sure it was everywhere
where people could see it
um the other thing that we were involved
is was over the last 10 years every year
um CVS's are given money by six County
Council in the way of warm homes funding
um The Wolves homes funding is to
support as it says they are one bedding
winter clothes winter coats personal
hygiene household items warm packs
Etc we worked with Partners including
scarfed for young carers rochwood
extended services local schools and we
were able to support hopeful Baptist
Church with household and bedding for
those in temporary accommodation as as
Kelly has mentioned a number of people
were housed in temporary accommodation
um because they couldn't pay their rent
and various other issues household
personal items in for food banks
food banks don't get donated they get
pasta they get beans they get tins of
soup but they don't really get personal
hygiene items or washing tabs but we
absolutely essential that people remain
clean and hygienic because it keeps them
healthy and therefore they then don't
put a strain on the Health Service which
is already under enough pressure in the
winter anyway we were able to support
with the funding 38 families made up of
53 adults and 67 children we were able
to support with school uniform in the
form of clothes and winter coats and
winter bedding therefore improving the
attendance of our young people at school
there is feedback from
um some local primary school and a local
partner which um it really says that we
make a difference
um and obviously when the pack is sent
out you can read it at your leisure
um there isn't a slide for this but I
just want to bring a couple of points to
your attention
it's been said already cost of living
isn't going anywhere
we are now in a situation where cost of
living has moved on from fuel to school
uniform
and with the support of councilors Mrs
Mason Mrs Wilson and Mrs Belton we have
been able to establish a reuse uniform
project which doesn't only support the
cost of living but it also supports the
climate change and the environment
agenda as well
um
there was a national report that talked
about the donations at charity shops the
donation of the charity shops are down
because people are now using selling
sites such as vintage and eBay because
they don't want to give their clothes
they weigh the money for themselves if
the charity shops Revenue goes down it
means that those Charities can't deliver
the support to people
and it's the same with food banks people
are not going to donate to food banks
because they need their food in their
own cupboards and
the number of people that can volunteer
is also down
um because people are back at work or
they're now doing child care so that
their children can go to work it sounds
it's all Blake but it's not there is the
tide is turning there is there is a
light at the end of the tunnel but I do
believe that we've got probably another
18 months to two years before things
really start to pick up
and finally this is a huge plug for me
if you want to come and learn more about
partnership collaboration and how
wonderful
pledges you can make to change the
health and well-being of our residents
please come and join me on Monday at the
member briefing session online half past
seven it's it's going to be fun we are
going to have presentations from some
outstanding people and really and at the
end of it there's a quiz with prizes so
please come and join me it's going to be
fun
right fine
uh good evening uh thank you very much
uh for allowing me to Showcase some
great work we're doing here at active
Essex so it's a great opportunity
um and also it just shows um the work
that we've um
been putting forward for the past year
I'm new in the role so it's great to
meet you guys as well so hopefully you
enjoy the presentations I think I've got
control because I might be the reason
we've got a lot of slides I just wanted
to Showcase a lot of information
but hopefully you see the value to the
work that we're doing and how it's
affecting Rochester residents so um the
program we're delivering is the Essex
activator program uh which is a funded
program from the Department for
Education which we are managing and uh
in charge of the delivery
um in the place we're a very place-based
organization
um and what we're doing is working with
in with the communities in Rochford to
build that Community resilience we're
not here to deliver it ourselves what
we're trying to do is provide that
organizational development and the
program is in place uh till 2025 and
we'll be delivering in Easter summer and
during the Christmas holidays from the
successes of this program we've actually
been awarded funding to deliver this on
the half term so we've seen the rise of
cost of living and how this program is
reaching out to communities further and
further each each holiday period
the core offer of the program is four
hours of delivery four days a week and
four days in Easter uh four weeks of
Summer and four days of Christmas so
that is the programming of the sessions
for providers to be uh engaged with and
delivering
what we do as Essex activate uh we've
got a staff team behind us and what we
provide for the clubs is theme resources
um that we look at every holiday period
for the main offer of the program is
physical activity because we want kids
moving providing enrichment
opportunities for the children so it's
not just purely based on physical
activity and what they will also receive
is a tasty nutritious meal as well
um during that holiday period we will
educate them for nutritional education
so they can continue to live uh Healthy
Lifestyles and what we do will be
mentoring support and time posting for
the whole family as well through other
organizations that we work with so they
may not just stick at a Holiday Club
they'll be other organizations within
Rochford that can support their children
another day we want to create Legacy
with those young children and families
um we're not just a typical primary Club
what we've done is we're quite um open
we do primary secondary we have mental
well-being in sessions into place and we
also look at send provision as well so
we're not just typically delivering
primary sessions so we are quite diverse
in the offer compared to the other areas
because it is a national program
the send offer the way we run the
program it's low level Center high level
so there are clubs that will take
one-to-one and complex needs so we've
put those measures in place and allowed
funding for
um organizations to apply for that high
level need if needed
we have worked with um wand e-vouchers
which is a system to ensure that we are
achieving the right uh reporting
monitoring evaluation and reaching out
to the right demographics this system is
allowing us to ensure that all children
are on benefit-based free School meals
are eligible for the program we also
have a 15 allocation to uh discretionary
for the clubs to offer that place for
anyone low income or need that support
because they may be vulnerable so we do
have a 15 allocation available so it's
not just all children on benefit free
school mail so we're quite open so we're
trying to push that more because we're
seeing that as a higher need now
especially in the place
we provide marketing Communications for
our clubs we're quite heavily involved
with that we provide activity booklets
so a child receiver booklet so they
won't just be receiving
um opportunities when they're physically
at the club they can also take these
booklets at home so it's a bit of a wrap
around uh opportunity for the children
parents can engage with the program and
do the program at home there's
opportunities for them to do arts and
crafts there's some affordable and free
activities that we ensure that is a
mentioned in the booklets for families
to be involved with
um all the sessions are signed posted on
our website and we provide leaflets so
we are heavily marketing this program to
ensure that we are reaching the right
Children and Families
as I mentioned the theme resources this
is always changing so I mean we
delivered on last year was the sun
safety obviously with cost of living we
ensured that we was able to provide
physical resources to our clubs and
Tackle skin cancer so what we did is we
provide educational resources of how to
protect yourself during the summer
months and each Club also received
sunscreen so as mentioned it's not just
come along Play We are looking at other
avenues of addressing Health
inequalities we've provided
skateboarding cycling sessions without
these opportunities these children might
not be able to engage with these
activities so we're pumping a lot of
different resources and opportunities
for those children rather than playing
your core sports football tennis
basketball they're having opportunities
of doing experiences as well food
education is uh key as well like I said
we've got a lot of uh food Workshop
organizations come in supporting
families doing networking workshops
doing family Cook alongs we're ensuring
that the sustainability is after the
program as well so they'll learn a lot
through the clubs and they'll be able to
take this home and be able to make
affordable uh food and recently we've
just been engaged with data banks so we
are now looking at providing SIM cards
to the eligible families to tackle data
poverty as you know
um this day and age uh this phone
contracts pay as you go is quite costly
we are providing 20 Gigabytes of SIM for
six months 40 gigabytes with talking
we've talked some calls as well
um as part of the package this will
obviously address
um
people finding jobs supporting their
children with homework so you can see
there's more theory behind it it's not
just giving out a SIM card everyone
these days they need to go online to
make an appointment with a GP so it's
tackling those little digital inclusions
so we provide a lot of theme resources
which is our physical activity spectrum
and it's completely based on cost of
living so that is a mix of uh what we do
as an active Essex team and the two and
the children and families and
organizations will do more of the
delivery program so we're here to
support and manage that program you
might think oh it's great they've
received a lot of money but there's a
need for it at the end of the day if you
look at Rockford as a Borough snapshot
the amount of residents claiming out of
work benefits uh increased has increased
to the highest level in five years
1560 children and young people a
recording of being low-income households
so you can see there's a need analysis
to this it's not just the fact
department for education this money
we've got a good set level of mapping
here once again you'll be able to gather
more data Insight that we've researched
to ensure that we're doing the program
for the right reasons
um
in the place
what I'm going to show is a video so
hopefully you enjoy it this is the
shortest video out of all the ones we do
um so please do relax and enjoy some of
the impacts for a video before I go into
a bit of the rich data so you've got a
bit of a breather
let's take a while to refresh
Because the Internet is it yeah
there'll be quite a few
oh there we go
small things
so I think it's fantastic from wonderful
back to the six I started yeah
which enables upstairs to come along
meet their friends try out the
activities have fun engaging positive
Sports
foreign
[Music]
children especially send offer and we're
also providing a dedicated to mental
health and well-being fund to make sure
that we can give families the maximum
support that we can during the summer
holidays students will be now uploading
it's been really good to play with my
friends and a lot of other people
it's really nice because we usually only
astounded personality the British
changes
I think you've got some great ideas
get involved
how many part of something
[Music]
thank you that's just a short snapshot
of a summer program yeah quite a while
ago we do have other videos like Kelly
mentioned more than happy to share those
as well so you can view them in your
leisure
pass on these are just a few more images
of what the children get act uh get
involved with arts and crafts
opportunities of skateboarding and some
enrichment and you can see the different
levels of clubs there as well
so this is more the rich date stuff you
might ask what is our reach in the
program
um I will obviously there's a bit of a
color here so what I'll do is just run
through some of the headline stats and
this will be shared so you'll be able to
Easy View but a year on from the program
needs to 22 in Rochford um because I
look after South Essex so all the data
I'll be presenting will be rotured based
so Easter 22 in Easter worked with five
primary clubs
um two cent clubs uh we offer 275 daily
spaces in total two one four two
thousand one hundred forty total spaces
were offered on seven days of delivery
so that's how much the funding is
allowed allowing us to reach some of the
stats from the Easter delivery and what
we received was during that period was
1575 attendances this was based on 319
unique children uh we distributed 1 575
nutritious meals 228 of the children
returned to the activate Club so we do
have a great level of uh retention
um and some of the data we found from it
is not just physical activity uh what we
found is
um high levels of scent parents were
able to send their children to a locally
trusted organization where they felt
confident that they could leave their
child to engage in enrichment physical
activity and also it increased
impairments mental well-being because it
was an opportunity for them to have
respite not child care but as an
opportunity of recipient so they're the
level of clubs that we provide through
our sense and this is a breakdown of
some of the stats and more data more
based on the lowest super output areas
so what I've done is we've mapped it the
provisioning what's happening each ward
in each regulator locality so as you can
see we had some delivery in Hockley Roch
North and Rural swim park and the Grange
Lodge and found us in a great way acres
and hawk or west so you can see we've
not just put out clubs in one area we've
tried to reach as many walls as possible
so hopefully that can show that we're
not just doing any old program we're
looking at the insight and programming
to what we're seeing and that was our
Rochford Easter delivery and this is
more of an overall during the whole
program just so you know a snapshot we
engage 319 in Rochford but the whole
Essex program in gauge 6017 unique
children so we've got a big reach on the
program summer 22 we increased our
program so we provided more Community
resilience in the place so six clubs six
primary clubs and one new secondary club
and two send clubs were part of the
program 300 daily spaces this increase
just purely because of the summer
program is longer 5465 total space is
available what we saw during that
picture was
4281 attendances and a reach of 579
unique children who were benefit-based
um children uh as part of the school
um and what we found this time we've got
rich data as in parents sending their
children to the program because they're
seeing positive role models from the
coaches married up with the data I love
my data and insight looking at it really
closely they were female responses
single parents and that role model is
that Father Figure so you can see once
again the program isn't just attacking
cost of living it's looking at other
areas of support as well this program
encompasses every strategic priority
that you could possibly think of and
that's what we try and pride ourselves
on and that was the Roger summer as you
can see
um there was increased Wards as part of
the program as well we had two in
founders awakens
um just a
a stat out there great waycroon has over
150 children benefit free School meals
so we started off with one provision in
there but we increased it to two because
we knew that insight there was more
children to engage with so we are
looking at that data locally
once again 519 children in Rochford but
the overall program uh 12 000 unique
children supported over the cross Essex
and we contribute to 500. Winter smaller
program five primary clubs one secondary
two send
1420 uh total spaces
um and once again the stats are high 905
attendances six organization across
seven clubs
264 unique children so you can see we
are still playing with a high level of
children engaging in the program and as
you can see we do break out to primary
secondary children so as you can see
that need is still there
um and in total
um a 20 26 000 Tendencies across the
program for winter just an example of
how many people are actually attending
the program as well we might be engaged
in unique but you can see what what the
conversion of attendance is as well so
Rockford as a whole in 2022 what we what
have uh distribute down is also the
amount of funding we've put in each uh
local uh output area so Hockley for
instance we invested 58 000 pounds to
run this program so as you can see the
value comes from money that is also in
the program Roger North 30 000 uh 397
swim park 20 386 large 38 000 found this
in a way crin's 37 000 Hawk pool West
hawkwind Hockley is changing to uh
combined super Alpha area that's 19 000
but for the purpose of today I've split
it up this was last year we are
committed to invest the same amount of
money this year as well uh through the
program
but some of the funding has increased
because it's based on the free School
meals
um
Easter 2023 six primary clubs one
secondary two cents so we're constantly
increasing the program delivered 2190
spaces and once again thousand
attendances 276 unique children so we're
still working with the same amount of
children as part of the program so the
reach is there and what
uh also sorry in Easter this year
talking about healthful quantities we
distributed 400 oral health packs so any
families that struggling with toothpaste
or dental hygiene we combated that so as
you can think of we're doing absolutely
everything
um
we're now also looking at more ways of
looking at Insight so we'll have got a
better relationship with the schools as
a place
2298 children are registered on free
School meals in Rochford that is our
current reach as mentioned from the
stats we're reaching anywhere from 300
to 500 so we definitely know there's
more for us to do part of that we are
struggling to do the reach based on the
amount of funding we we receive so
there's a certain amount of uh uh
barriers we do have but we try and
promote as many spaces as we can
in Easter 92 of the schools release
their code so it's having that
partnership with the scores and
management information system so that
was um based on 27 schools that are in
the Rochford District
um and that's just a few stats of uh
Easter again you see hot hot attendances
in that Ward 185 pounds in awakens so
like I mentioned to you we had 140
Redstone free School meals we've got
people coming out of the awards going to
that provision because they might prefer
that as well so we are providing the
right amount of reach to the children
if you don't mind me interjecting I
think um our counselors will be able to
ask some more questions if that's okay
yeah and um I have to declare an
interest members
um active Essex wasn't actually on our
guest list on our agenda
um so I'm declaring an interest because
I'm a trustee with ATF okay all right
thank you so members we're now going to
first of all we have a report in front
of us and we will ask questions to the
report first of all so that's item six
and then we will go on to have a chat
with our guests around um their projects
so
um have I got any questions and when you
do raise them could you please refer to
what page number and which item if
that's okay thank you Council across
thank you chair
um my question relates to uh page 6.1
item 1.1
um
rosford councils focused on sick key
themes which are all mentioned there my
question is
um what communication methods were
employed and when when were those
communication methods put into action
they were put into action straight away
so one of the things we did is like I've
said at the very beginning of the this
evening it's not what the council were
going to do it's about supporting and
signposting so the website was put into
play from the very outset on what we did
we developed a um by your side Campaign
which was not just because we're very
well aware not everybody is digital so
it needs to be in printed format we
worked with our partners so it's about
getting the information that residents
need at the first point of contact so
that will be our warm hubs or Community
groups and mega Center through wraps so
it was set up from the very outset and I
think the bio side campaign ran until
February and that got national attention
actually so it was very well received
but yeah it was almost from the very
beginning the first Focus was getting
the website up and running and that was
became a huge Focus because it changed
at the beginning fairly regularly so we
had to update it on almost on a daily
basis but it was just about making sure
that that information was available at
the first point of contact we also
developed various other things around
um when we first set up the working
group I always say I dragged the police
along and I felt really guilty because
they sat there and they're a bit like I
really have a part to play in it and the
sergeant came in at the last minute and
said look I don't really have much
involvement in the cost of living but
what we will do is we'll be involved in
the the the serious end where there
could be domestic violence around
Financial pressures and those kind of
things it would be really helpful if we
had something that we could give to the
residents or show a QR code on our
um their devices that they take out so
we developed that as well so that was
something unique to us which was was
really really well received and used by
sixth place thank you Tracy my question
um I was trying to tease out really what
was available to to aged population
people that could barely afford to pay
electricity bills for instance let alone
have internet connection so a lot of a
lot of the medium does seem to be
digitally based and and that's admirable
but when we had the webinar uh in
September last year I believe I
mentioned what was actually going to be
printed matter and delivered
you know to to every household really
and did that happen
right well yeah I've made it very clear
and I will make it very clear again
everything we put in printed format is
out of date from the moment we put it
and everything we give out will direct
people to our website so actually it's
not about and I've resisted this in
Brentwood and I've resisted it here we
need to make sure that the residents get
the support and the help and the advice
and the guidance at the first point and
the easiest point to put something
through somebody's letterbox would have
just included a list of websites what
they can access so what we've done is
we've worked with our community groups
so that when and sorry to be a motive
when Betty goes to the hug in a shrug
she can get that information and advice
in person because there's nothing better
than that in-person advice and it was
about making sure that the campaign
reached those through the social media
mechanisms that we all have through word
of mouth and encouraging people to speak
to their neighbors and giving them that
advice and like we said on the webinar
you know there are people out there that
have access to the internet if you bring
Betty over for a cup of tea and you can
access the website then you can help us
through that so it's just about making
sure that that information is available
and unfortunately all of the information
that's out there is digital in the sense
that they can access websites so I
didn't see the relevance of putting that
in a printed format it's about going out
there and having a whole raft and I
think we've got a 50-point action plan a
whole raft of mechanisms where we can do
that through our partners and one of the
things that we've developed in part ship
with our partners is videos and bits and
pieces like that that we can send out
through our social media networks that
people can then watch
um through various different devices but
yeah it's it's a moving feast
and I I'm always focused on delivering
what the community need where they need
it rather than just ticking a box and
getting something through somebody's
letterbox because that doesn't
necessarily achieve what we want to
achieve
um if it's okay we're going to come back
to our guests afterwards because we've
got to talk on the paper at the moment
thank you Victoria
um I I'm just going to follow up on um
Council across these um questions uh
when we had the um the start of covid
and the Rayleigh Hub was opened up and
you used to have the call center there
um there was a house to house leaflet
drop
that worked okay so Leaf there is still
a place for leaflets
um
now
I'm referring to page 6.1 1.2 around the
website
it actually says that it's updated
weekly
now
um my concern is I actually went on and
tried some of those links
one of them's got information from 2022
I found more current
um
uh information on the government website
which would be useful for our residents
um included around the 10 10.1 increased
estate pension and also um the amount
that they're giving for people with
disabilities since April 2023
um the warm Hub information on there was
not correct I'm afraid
um and with the food banks it would have
been nice to have seen some cross-border
work some of our resident residents live
so close to South End that's quite
useful if they can have the information
of those if they're on a bus route or
something like that to get to so
um that's just a little bit of feedback
for the website please
um if I can't counseling I'll just come
back on that point
um what I would say is this isn't you
know that we have a very very small team
so if I just put a plea out there if any
member comes across anything that may be
out of Doubt or you think we've missed
something like we say to our partners at
the working group let us know and we can
change it and adapt it as we go along
because we're not the experts a lot of
my officers I say officers I mean Kelly
bless her you know she will scam will
work across both organizations but we
will miss information so it'd be really
helpful if you could let us know that at
the first point you you see it
um and Tracy I think Council Booth is
going to come in because when we had our
pre-meet he came out with a um fairly
um viable option so Council Booth so I
was just wondering after what you've
said in our pre-meeting is updating the
website weekly is that achievable with
the staff and the team that you actually
have at the moment or is there a longer
period where things are updated it on
the website so the website apologies the
website is set up to link you directly
out to what we understand is the most
relevant information that is information
that sits on citizens advice it sits on
local government web pages we don't get
given the nod when that information is
updated so it is really a cluster job of
going through the links and doing it
individually and as as a single officer
there's not enough resource for us to do
that weekly and and that's because we
have different issues come up at
different times
if you do come up with relevant
information I just want to support
traces please send it to us we are more
than happy for anyone that gathers or
half as information particularly local
information please send it to us and
we'll get that updated as a priority the
it the web team do it quickly they're
really responding to us and our needs
but I can't keep that information you
know the information is only as good as
the day it was printed or published and
that's particularly relevant to central
government information
thank you
thank you Kelly and that's just
highlighting what we thought because to
say it was updated weekly
um you know that that isn't something
that you can manage at the moment
um and perhaps uh again if we can pop
something out to our member agencies if
they see changes that they can also
alert you to add to those that would be
great
um uh councilor Mrs page
thank you chairman
um my questions page 6.2 item 1.3
um I would like a little bit more
clarity around this statement concerning
the plan to Ben in September 2022 I
think you mean 2023
and equally
um why are we having another event in
Rayleigh why we're not spreading it out
in the district maybe in the east
thank you so the first event wasn't a
Rochford District Council event it was a
castle point in Rochford health and
wellbeing board event what I enabled to
do which we do across the board for cost
of leaving was tag cost of living on
it's relevant and it's focused but
actually it wasn't the main event this
new event is an opportunity to use our
assets to be supported by the asset team
to use this venue
The Mill Hall and to use the venue
supported by rainbow Town Council over
at the fields and to use some of the
assets that we've got so that actually
we're not trying to create an event
we've got no resource or funding for
it's actually about working with the
partners working with active Essex
working with the mega Center and
creating something out of what they do
every day that meets the needs we'd love
to be able to do it
across the district would love to be
able to do it multiple times the
organization and the planning and the
cost is is Hefty
um as I say the reason that we was able
to be so successful with the last event
and the reason that we're planning this
off of it is because it was done off the
back of the health and wellbeing board
and the work and the strategy there
which wholly supports the cost of living
it's the gender item on the health and
wellbeing boards meetings we do discuss
it and partners give what input that
they can cost of living
is not Central to everybody's work it's
a fact of life
it's a threat in between actually the
focus for for that work was health and
well-being so this one will be different
this is owned by Rochford Council and
partners it's moving it along maybe next
year we can get out and and get to the
Rochford area
and replicate it that would be the plan
but it's one one event at a time
thank you Kelly does that answer your
question Council page okay I actually
quite like the idea and I want to talk
about it about exploring that with the
community
um Supermarket because if you've got a
mobile unit we could be taking some more
information out with that food but we'll
talk about that in a moment um councilor
[Music]
um
uh yeah I noticed that in 1.8 6.3 the
there's a live action plan and I think
you mentioned earlier though that you
could be sharing that with members uh
directly
um because as it's an evolving situation
and project
um just for that that reason so is it
possible to to share the that action
plan as it evolves so we can just look
at it more than happy to share that
councilor Mill and previously it's been
shared through exec the first time we've
come to overview in scrutiny
it's important that I do it with the
caveat that this action plan was for 22
23.
the data that we've got compliments that
actually the steps forward as Victoria
has said and all of our partners we know
a lot different at this time we need to
simplify it down some so I'm happy to
send it it is live but it's not
necessarily relevant going to look
forward to 23 24. so please look at it
with that caveat in mind and I will be
going out to engage so it's my purpose
to get this conversation going again
over summer for the next section plan it
comes to eltclt at the end of September
it will inevitably come back to reset or
overview in scrutiny for what that
action plan will look like and we will
engage with members we want it to be a
bit more realistic and a little less
Council Focus if you like moving forward
but I'm more than happy to show that
alongside the um the documents for today
which I will split up into separate
um presentations so you can bite-size
them well thank you I can see from the
partners actually there's an awful lot
going on so obviously you're doing
something right here
um on the hashtag buyerside is 1.5
there's only one one query uh obviously
that's a Twitter hashtag is it yeah
because when you just run it on Google
you come up with either a pop song or
help for people with cancer and there's
nothing about helping but obviously if
it's Twitter and and people would know
that if they go through the website
wouldn't they so it was the social media
campaign predominantly but it was also a
poster campaign so it's um if you go
into the leaves probably here actually
you should find a hashtag buy your
Fireside campaign a poster on the back
of the loo they certainly are at um the
Roxford offices they're all over the
Brentwood office so what they were was
one of the tools out of the toolkit and
that toolkit was shared with all
Partners so we wasn't just sharing that
it wasn't just on social media they were
pretty dark they were displayed in
Partners organizations and that's where
the commons
um becomes
um
versatile so we produced some cons but
actually the network
took the message yeah forgive me for
that because I was just looking at it
from the point of view of a dinosaur
trying to think what it was
everything needs a gimmick and hashtag
by your side was the was the gimmick by
which my partners could say actually we
we signed into cost of living and we can
share that because we're going to be
more alive then in this next year with
ideas and all the team Danielle and all
those uh Sarah Jones feeding in yeah
thank you
thank you councilor Mill and for our
officers at least they can see we do do
our homework as well
um is there any more questions on the
paper yes counselor
God can I just say the work that all of
you do is very commendable and you
should have recommended for it but the
only observation I would make from all
four of you have said only one person
has mentioned fairness and white Rings
everything that seems to be going on
appears to be happening in Rayleigh and
if people can't get to Rayleigh then it
doesn't mean pretty much there is that
my is that a wrong observation or can
you actually
okay so do you actually know what
percentage your uh people you help come
from outside really and counseling says
um if we can just hold those questions
Joe individually to each partner rather
than putting them on the spot is that
okay yep no problem is there any more
questions on the paper
councilor Mrs Payne
yes it's um page 6.3 2.1
um
can you let me know what the budget is
or let committee know what the actual
budget is do we have an idea
there is no resources
here we had five thousand pounds from
the leaders pot which was given director
revs for warm homes
there is no additional resources from
Rochford District Council perspective
put towards cost of living last year to
facilitate this work
it is out of existing budgets on your
existing staff which have been me one
full-time officer which deals with
health and well-being
um and and a lot of
um support across the council to try and
coordinate the data so I understand that
dashboard wasn't perfect we could ask a
million things from it but actually it's
the data from the officers and the work
that we do
I want to be aspirational and I hope
that with your help we can do that I
will make a point so I've we've just
done the voluntary sector Grant process
with counselor Gooding and an
independent members panel that decision
should come to the next executive but
one of those bids was around cost of
living one of those bids was made by the
mega center around cost of living and a
thousand pound Grant will be going to
then specifically for cost of living
work at the voluntary sector grants but
at the 10 000 pound pot all of those
projects in some way support cost of
living and parents and families so at
the moment it's it's a zero but you know
think about that because resources will
mean more work and more support
um um members are visible to say that
this report is only for noting but that
does not stop us from doing an exercise
and making future recommendations that
this uh sort of work is supported more
by our Council
um so we're now going to progress on if
there's no more there is some more
questions uh councilor watum please
thank you madam chairman
um on the particular report 1.1
um the six bullet points there uh are
very helpful
um but uh I think we've alluded to five
of them this evening
um but when we talk about support to go
green I guess in the light of the um the
item on the council agenda a week or two
ago uh we'll see this uh cropping up but
I think we've got to understand what go
green means within the context of cost
of living
um and by that I mean that I see on the
website he talks about insulation and
that's absolutely right I support it
it's about cutting energy costs but
there is a capital cost to insulation so
we need to give a steer as to whether or
not there's any grants to assist people
uh to obviously keep their costs and I
think we need to make sure we're not
being disingenuous in terms of the cost
of living Heading by slipping in go
green without actually providing a clear
differential between a capital cost to
save money and investor save and
actually a green initiatives that could
help people and that's my particular
comment on the paper Madam chairman
thank you thank you council Mrs Belton
all right
in that case I think um
if our guests guests are happy do you
want to do this on mass or would you
like us to ask your individually yes on
that right so there we go in that case
our first question will come from
councilor Mrs Milton
thank you
um first off thank you for the
presentations it was a reminder of the
great groups we have in the district and
how lucky we are
um Scott you mentioned Pride at the
beginning I certainly feel proud to be
part of a council that has been able to
support groups over the last year and
years prior to that and I hope that as
councilor page mentioned that there'll
be budgets coming forward to support
more of the good work that you will do
um so a few questions in their
Collective not for anyone in particular
so from the work that's been done over
the last year and obviously there's a
lot of partners that have been um worked
with do you feel what you're missing any
Partners do you have people come to you
asking for support and you don't
actually have a partner to signpost them
to or do we feel that most faces are
covered at the moment and we're pretty
much got it got it from all angles
um
no we um as a community resilience Hub
we have got access to lots and lots of
different partners
um and what we do say to people is we've
got one phone number we've got one email
address whatever your question is you
contact us you ask us and if we can't
help ourselves we will know somebody who
can thank you and we speak we speak to a
central government we've been to Essex
we speak to us on the phone today to uh
Edward County Council about refugees or
Ukraine that's been housed in our
district
um this morning as nowhere to live in
through those times so we just we
collaborate with our partner
organizations in different districts
because we don't just worked in Rockford
we work for the whole culture
I'd like to sweats that
are not just the solution they make
Solutions so those gaps that do come up
and I think that cost of living is where
they've stepped up but if we go back to
the hub and the kovid response and
remind ourselves that the Hobbies a
collection of over 30 Partners if
there's a gap we are a little Rochford
but we are small and mighty and they
will do their best to support those
needs it might not be a service it might
not be a full package of support but no
one's there's no one left behind and I
think we can commend the partners on
that okay thank you um you've got more
questions haven't you for our partners
and if it's okay if our partners answer
those questions officers thank you
um thank you so just going into the data
um and obviously it was a high level we
couldn't see all of the specifics but
there looked to be potentially some
discrepancy and I wonder and that may
come out in the wash when we look at it
so for example the the dashboard data
um would imply that the data is the same
from last year to this year however then
when we've heard the mega centers data
and active Essex data
um we've got down that benefits are on a
five-year high and also that food
Parcels are almost double from last year
now I appreciate we only saw a snapshot
of the data and it could be that some
Services have gone up and others have
come down and that's why the numbers are
the same but do we think we're missing
something is there a reason the data
isn't collaborating or could it simply
be what I've suggested that some
Services have come right down others
have gone up as you've alluded to
earlier
right yeah I think there's a there's a
mixture of stuff I work with data quite
closely where we're seeing data still
part of the old census and we're still
waiting for data to feed into us there's
so much that we can actually capture on
the ground and convert it into Rich data
so we are as a collective I I would say
we are a bit behind on some of the
points what we're working with is more
of those for instance if we're using
free School meals as an example the only
way we're going to find that data is
directly from the schools if parents are
not updating their eligibility we're not
going to receive that data until next
year and also there may be discrepancies
throughout the years because a child on
free School meals for instance may stay
on the system for longer so it's a
mixture of what date is coming up coming
to us from those levels from local
Insight or the dashboards for us to then
act upon it so what we try and do is
more do try and look at the hyper local
and more of the Insight by going to the
place and understanding it and that's
that's just an example of One Piece to
work through the half program as you can
see it's developed from more work and
more Community organizations
understanding what our reach is in a
place by going and speaking to them
individually hence that call of action
there for Great Awakening we identified
x amount of free School meals and we
acted upon it similar to other data that
we're receiving as well and that's just
a bit of background I've seen from data
and how I'm working with it we can only
go by what we can actually see in front
of us as well yeah and our data in terms
of the mega Center data that you see
it's just the reality of what it is so
we you know the other days that you are
presented this evening we wouldn't have
seen that data before the meeting so I
can't we I can't personally comment on
that because we we have seen it
okay you gave the presentation for the
cab so of course yeah if you want to
feedback um please do
so what's interesting is that data from
Department of work and pensions that
tells us that that um that's been
accessed for the hap program isn't
necessarily available that I would
immediately access for this report at
this time and it wouldn't necessarily be
reflected in the calls received by
citizens advice for example so we may
have had an uplift in people receiving
benefits but that not may not be the
priority as you said in the issues or
the concerns that have been raised at
citizens advice or we can go on with the
date dashboard is a comparison of the
data given by all Partners it doesn't
give us a complete picture it's just a
flavor
and also just to add
if you take data cancer event the
building out the way also you have to
see that there's Community activity and
Community
um going on so what we found in the mega
center with the community Hub is you
know
our our community
are very resourceful in helping each
other okay so so you know you've got
data that you know people might be
better or not so um
or a better State than others but like
yeah we've found you know elderly people
who have got greater pensions and the
new generation will ever get well us
giving food banks to people in their
street because so that's not on the data
that's just Community being community
and so we mustn't we mustn't forget that
that happens quite substantially in our
in our district so that that's nothing
to do with data so sometimes the data
can say something completely different
than the reality of what's actually
happening in our community you know an
old person comes to the mega cents we're
Banks he said well I'm being retired
from the Civil Service for 20 years I
have more money than my children will
ever have so here's here's 12 food
Parcels you know remember that
I may just come back very quickly last
point and completely agree and that's
Testament to the work that's being done
because people aren't needing to call
Citizens advice because they know where
to find you all because of the the
social media outreach the word of mouth
and actually less caused a Citizens
advice even though there's more people
having food banks is Testament to the
work groups like yourselves are doing
and the signposting that's coming from
Oxford so thank you again uh sorry
council members and just to come back on
your point is the fact that people or
phone rabs and say where is my local
food bank that will be called a
statistic of information given we have
no idea if they ever act on that
information and then people as Julie
said will go to the makers everybody get
food parcel they never have phoned us so
I do think there will be disparities
throughout the data
thank you uh councilor Sperry
[Music]
um
this is no way a criticism of the work
you do I mean I've been involved with it
so I under fully understand what you're
doing but in future may I suggest that
any slides that you're going to present
to us we see beforehand because as far I
don't know how other people have found
I've been swamped with information this
evening
um figures that really if I'd have had a
bit of time to look at some of this
stuff I might have been able to ask some
more constructive questions
um
don't love school
um but the one thing that that did stick
out to me
um about loads of other aspects you've
highlighted I think six areas where you
utilize your sites during the school
holidays but
um are they I don't quite know how
you've done this how you've picked these
are you going to use the same sites in
future or are you going to move them
around to other
to other wards
so we um we run a procurement process
um so any organization a processes can
apply to be a hold active in food Club
they go through scoring and then what we
do is we look at the data sitting behind
it so it's actually based on how many
children on free School meals at that
place for us to mobilize a club in that
obviously the clubs that we would like
to see are your trusted location like
School settings so they will always
remain but there are also opportunities
for communities To Go in different
places so what we're trying to do is not
have too many clubs in one Ward or one
area we want to see more applications
and try and direct more children more
families being signed posted to one area
but equally if organizations not coming
forward to deliver we do have a struggle
but then that's where we are building
that Community resilience some of these
clubs are actually delivering at two
locations and we've gone to them and say
look there's a high level of need in
this area is there an opportunity for
you to deliver a program for that so for
instance Carlson point Orchard School
sports partnership they're a trusted
organization they do a lot of work in
schools they started off in Castle point
now they're in two locations in
Rochester from the data we're seeing of
how many children are and based on free
School meals in that catchment so we try
and ensure that there is a club in the
high levels of play in the high levels
of need areas same with great Waker as
well we have two clubs in there because
we've identified there's a high need in
there so we try and put that data in
front of them and they use that to apply
as the program so every year or every
half term there could be new providers
coming forward and we'll work with them
to expand and like I said we don't just
say here's some money go ahead and
deliver we provide training for the
providers as well so we're we're
building their organization to have more
staff that could deliver in more
locations so we're always looking at
different areas based on the need
um that we're seeing thank you very much
thank you thank you councilor sparing um
are mine four members that we have got a
long agenda we're only on a gender item
number one so if we can keep questions
succinct that would be brilliant Council
award
yeah it will be six inch actually
um I was very interested in your idea of
wanting to have a supermarket where it
could be for the community
now I I know in Suffolk
um this is something that will give you
a bit of a headache but I'm sure you
personally Scott will really want to
have a go at this
um the farming Community actually do get
together in Suffolk and it's quite
amazing because there's a place called
La Hogue which is on in the elveden
estate
um and within that they have this
massive Supermarket which is provided by
the community and people go there in
preference to any other Supermarket
because the food is a lot cheaper
because it cuts out the middleman
totally it's direct from the farmers the
farmers like it because they're actually
putting into the community they actually
get more out of it themselves because
they're robbed by the supermarkets
basically and they prefer it
um what was interesting again this
refers to something that happened a
couple of weeks back
um we had an application that came
through uh which would have allowed
sheep to graze under solar and I saw
this quite often in Suffolk and this was
interesting the cost and the price of
lamb is a lot cheaper especially in the
Hogue where they've got their own avatar
and Butchery and they were actually
providing cheap lamb to people it was
fantastic and you know this was an
opportunity that we may have later on
it's going to be difficult to start up
but maybe Scott with your
entrepreneurial skills You may wish to
look at something like that in going to
the farming community and start sorting
something out I've got 200 foot garden
I've got llamas in it already
um I think you know all I can say is you
know in terms of the community a great
idea and we've already listened back to
purchase a a van at the mega Center and
we're already talking to partners aren't
we ladies with um Life Church and other
partners about you know this game out of
this community
um fan with stuff in
um yeah but something it's an
interesting idea we might look at
uh certainly well someone to look at but
uh and like I said I've got the llamas
in my garden don't tell much of this
account so that they're in my gardening
thank you
members uh anybody else indicating to
ask a question
yes
no no I've got some questions as well
just to respond to I don't sorry
counselor I can't see your name
so
miles
are you friends by your name anyway
never mind just to say in terms of
Flyers
um we know because we were involved in
it they went to loads of doctors
surgeries all over the district
um I know that because my wife's a GPM I
know that because we delivered lots of
them
um in terms of the food bank um just in
the context of that
um don't forget that the organization
that we facilitate the Hub we don't just
work in districts we work in the
community so we work with castlepoint we
work with South End we work with
Basildon so in terms of the food bank
and the food bank Provisions about Essex
you know we all talk to it we talk to
each other all the time so our feedback
that makes sense at the moment is really
really depleted
um uh because we support can be as well
so we all talk to each other and have
conversations often uh about how we can
best support each other so so for
instance canvas having a really big
surge
um okay we're all going to can because
our our suppliers are getting outdated
enough
um our food bank but before we're having
a big search and stuff and I'm just find
it to say that the the people that work
at the Hub in in the mega Center we work
all over the district so going back to
your point about great way for it we
have um we're just about to extend our
charity staff um by four uh in September
um which is great um because the
business is doing so well and we're
working great work and we've got
statistics we've got figures because
everybody workers tells us who they are
but also we also we also we also work
with Partners in South End who say
um when we talk about something about
working we often say to look we're here
you're there you're in South End can you
resource that family I know you're in
South End you're not in their District
but we do a lot of that you know across
organic Partnerships so I can think of
four or five families in great waycroon
that we've helped but I could also think
of many that South End our colleagues in
south end at run hubs and the the
refugee so the refugees we've been doing
that a lot all over talking about crisis
we haven't went to the refugees and
they're across the living crisis but so
we do do just for your confidence we do
do a lot like cross-organic partnership
where we work with different
organizations and different boroughs to
make sure that we resource each other as
effectively as we can so I had a phone
call like I said today somebody come
into our district now we will then say
well let's see if we can speak to Castle
point or if we can speak to South End
and we all talk tomorrow morning on a
conference call and we'll find out what
we can do to Resource that person so
sometimes this watch is responding
sometimes it's classical Point
responding but at the end of the day as
far as we're concerned as an
organization and we don't we don't work
for trip we work for the community of
people in South well we're east
Southeast I'm sorry I'm not a local boy
Southeast Essex so I hope that gives you
confidence but um yeah um you know we do
have statistics which we can't we can't
openly tell you every story but to be I
just want to give you confidence that it
is a bit far away but there's people
have been looked after
um and I I know the family go and use
the Ark in shoebury
um and perhaps you can help
um our staff with that dating perhaps
that list of
um food food banks whether they're
within the district or outside
um
no I forgot to press the silly button
thing right
um right to to count to come back on
what councilor Myers asked um in the
presentation and I take counselor
experience Point there's a lot of data
up there
out of the 19 warm hubs that we opened
the only one that we opened in Wake ring
although we reached out to the groups in
wakering is was Cameo the ladies group
that meets the church they opened as a
warm space so that was the only warm
space but they received funding later
because they came forward later but we
did have at least one warm space in
wakering or the waking and they found
this and the white princess get the
water right
um to answer a councilor McPherson's I
believe it was your point about the
cross-border food bank my presentation
presents the fact that we also support
Eastwood Baptist Church I know it comes
under south end but they deliver they
support a number of families in Raleigh
and holbridge we also have in past last
winter supported the Salvation Army in
shubri to reach out to those families in
wakering that are on a bus route and
finally to answer Council across his
question which was a long time ago in
terms I am passionately I am not
believing Council across at the Arts
digital is everything so when we came to
the warm spaces my lovely colleague
Lindsay used to go out on a fortnightly
basis and update the poster in doctor
surgeries because we believe if you're
going in for a blood test or a diabetes
check you're going to read the poster so
I don't believe that I I believe that
there is an opportunity to use the
Publications which are delivered to
every household such as what should
roundabout and Rayleigh Vision to be
able to reach those people because they
are delivered to every household with a
very minimal expense for an advert so I
do believe it is something that yeah I
think it's worth an exploration anyway
okay thank you Victoria and just talking
about
um um those sort of papers there's often
the usual Parish magazines that you can
um advertise in
um Victoria the
um Hub in weight ring there's actually
two that they funded to we have
Wednesdays and Thursdays they're both
still thriving around 80 people still go
yes it's not cold they don't go there to
get warm but it's reducing their social
isolation which is brilliant
now just having a look through so you've
mentioned thank you make a send to the
Outreach that you do it would be
interesting
um the only uh partner that I saw gave a
breakdown of users across the district
was yourself bash it would be
interesting to see where the users come
from across our district especially when
you're talking about those lower super
output areas and the families that we
want to Target and Kelly is going to
tell me something on that one in a
minute
um and with um the hubs that are still
running if the cab could come out and do
some Outreach that would be absolutely
superb
and my last question will be to you bet
is regarding some of the activities
um I know that the schools give out a
code for people to register my only
reservation there is how we can support
you to access more funding just so that
those other children can take part
because it just seems a little bit
um unfair
um that they may want to go along with
their best friend but their best friend
can't go because they're not receiving
the support from the school okay thank
you if you could just come back on those
um if you if you don't mind I'll come
back from the data question as an
officer data I love data I do but date
is only as good as
the person providing it and what I have
to say particularly in terms of cost of
living data quite often people don't
want to provide information it's an
added pressure for a charity or an
organization we know there's more food
banks they don't want to tell us what
their what their numbers are they don't
need to take that time out so when
you're talking about voluntary sector
you know
um District level organizations they do
it they do it well they do it on their
own
we found that in covid so the data that
we clicked is is reflective so if we
can't actually get just the Bare Basics
data around the food banks for example
how many packages are being given out
across the board they're not going to go
and collectate on who they're giving it
to when they're giving it to how many
times they've given it to so data is
limited to the capacity of the
organization collecting it and their
Good Will in sharing it with us because
we don't fund any of these organizations
directly for a piece of work so actually
the collection and the delivery of the
data to us is also done on Goodwill
um so it's a delicate question and
that's why we try to mix up the quantity
of the solid data with some of the
qualitative and the stories that you
hear
and finally just from bash yeah we were
obviously the mates said that we work in
partly about we've got a school uh
holiday clubs have a mega Center so just
like our point is when we work with
organization like activistics so there's
two Charities working together so you
know let's let's call them Fred friends
come to the make Center for this gets
through School meals but Fred wants to
be his best mate Ben then what we do is
we communicate with that and then the
mega Center will sponsor the child
called Fred to go over his face mate
Charlie
um so so that does happen um but
obviously baz will tell you that there's
still lack of funding but where that's
possible uh we try and make that happen
by us resourcing it as a charity and
then resourcing it to charity as well
thank you I think I can let you off bash
because that answers it perfectly oh
I think this is a great partnership work
with Scott they're able to leverage some
funding to part fund it but that's not
happening at every Club not every Club
so there is a call for Action if there
is budget we will happily deliver what
you're asking with anyone else out of
that 15 we clearly know there's a need
we're very limited to finances it comes
down for Department of Education it's
based on free School meals that's what
we deliver that's what we have
unfortunately so if there was anything
we would happily um support that and
ensure that the funding was used the
right criteria thank you
um on behalf of the whole committee
um thank you so much for coming in
tonight it has been really enlightening
on around your work
um I think we'd like to have these
guests back if if they're willing to
come back
um perhaps you know in in a year's time
or six months or something
um so members um there is uh just for
this item item six to be noted is that
noted members thank you thank you so
much for coming along this evening we
can't thank you enough
thank you
members would you all like a five-minute
Comfort break yeah
oh yeah members if you could um take
your seats that'd be wonderful thank you
foreign
okay members
okay item seven the cost of living
payments to Residents
um
our interim director of resources Tim
Willis will introduce this report if
possible at speed because you have had
the report in front of you
um to view and then we'll go through any
questions
thank you chair
um
Council agreed on the 21st of February
that this committee set up a working
group to consider whether or not payment
should be made to Residents to reflect
the cost of living crisis
this report proposes that such a group
be set up with draft terms of reference
attached as appendix health
any financial implications arising from
the working group's deliberations can be
considered as they are formed as well as
by this committee when the group reports
back
some of the cost of servicing the
working group can be contained within
existing budgets but any research and
detailed exploration of options made Tim
I'm just going to stop you um does
anybody know where council Mrs page is
Tim carry on
may require additional funding for which
there is no budget thank you
my members what we're looking for here
is we're going to nominate members for a
working group the suggested number is
five now what I would like to say is
that we are going to look to make a
couple more working groups so think
carefully if this is one that you would
like to be on
um if you would like to be a member of
this working group please raise your
hand
thank you councilor Mrs Gadsden
councilor Booth councilor sparing
any more members
council Mrs Pedro looking for um
nominations to be on the working group
okay we have three I will put myself on
that working group as well we've got
four
um thank you very much councilor Mrs
Belton and of course we can call other
members who we feel that will add value
to this working group to join us so we
have the five names there
did you want to ask questions sorry
um what should be the question this was
um something put forward by a councilor
Mr Hoy and green independent and I
wonder if it might make sense because he
had a lot of a lot of ideas about it
would it be good to have someone from
his group representing his voice
a very good suggestion um councilor belt
and I had a note of it myself so yes we
will
um our ass on you if she could do that
for us if that's okay thank you
so members that's for recommendation we
have the names for the um working group
um we would like for that working group
to be able to feed back
to this committee at the September
meeting
thank you
sorry counselor Mrs Belton thank you
chair will members be contacted about
the first meeting and who will that
contact come from that come from Sonia
[Music]
the members of the working group are
councilors Mrs um Elton Mrs Gadson
councilor sparing councilor booth and
councilor McPherson
plus one independent where we're going
to approach Council Ahoy
uh Sonia will email all those members of
the working group thank you members
agenda item a one team transformation
program
um our strategic officer
um Greg Campbell will introduce this
report
thank you chair I'll be as quick as I
can we share because you've had the
report before you to read this is
quarter one of year two of the uh one
team program service reviews uh just to
give a quick update HR as you can see
and Communications have gone through the
process consultation and have employed
we've got risk management and emergency
planning at the moment out to
consultation and customer contact and
procurement will be before the program
board later yet we're in July later this
month all other social views are
progressing we've moved into phase two
as you can see on the list there are a
number of areas that are going through
the process desperate over the next
three to four months and we have learned
as we've gone along we've discussed it
with staff how they've progressed and
we've made some changes to make sure
there's a Slicker process and we're
getting better at it as we move it on we
continue with that we work with the
staff to make sure that they're on board
with the journey that we're taking as
well happy to take any questions thank
you Greg Greg um members um questions
counselor Mrs Belton
thank you sorry I'm not sure how to
point to the paper on it because it's
sort of to do with the phasing and also
the the risk report
um would you like to find your place
because I know counselor um a booth is a
question
sorry
um page 8.6 paragraph 3.12 it states
that the budget is split between uh
Watford and Brentwood but the split is
undisclosed so how and where is this
information recorded
so I just go down confirm it was six
point
eight point six
3.12 3.12 yeah that's right budget is
split between uh Roxford and Brentwood
but the split is undisclosed how and
where is this recorded
uh so um the split the the the budget is
provided by both authorities it's uh
uh 50 50 budget that was provided at the
start of the process so the budget is
then split between the two groups as
different service reviews move on but
it's generally a 50 50 spend on those
those at the time because the budget is
50 50. and we agree between those boxes
what that money is being spent on
because I want your question counselor
booth yes thank you okay
that's Mrs Belton thank you for giving
me that few seconds
um so a couple of things page 8.9 the
table this is um really useful to see in
this format so that we can assess the
risk in a more visual way
um and I'm pleased to hear that we have
um the new leadership has supported the
one team so that risk has now reduced
because that obviously was a huge risk
potentially had things needed to have
changed
um and then sort of on the point of risk
page 8.2
0.3.2 the table and human resources and
resourcing and we still have a number of
interim
um directors within the one team set up
and is there a plan and a time scale in
place to ensure that we aren't left
without vital team members that could
then again increase the one team risk
thank you councilor Belson um there is a
plan in place with the interim directors
that we have at the moment
um so they're already being spoken to
and there is a succession plan on what's
going to happen so there is an interim
director that we've made an approach to
who's staying on longer
um just to make sure that we're covering
the risk that we need to
um who's insisting too far from me
um and there are other two directors
that have stepped up at the moment who
are filling the place and we're
reviewing that process as it goes along
to see where we come out to but there is
a time scale to it as well
thank you just that answer your question
thank you chairman uh yeah this is on uh
page 8.9 it's actually the appendix
um just wanted some clarification on the
risk owners
um we've just got initials there it
would be useful to know who they are and
identify them if there was a code
somewhere so that we could know that
that would be very helpful thank you
FairPoint thank you
thank you uh any other members that um
indicating before I follow up with a
couple questions
no okay
um
[Applause]
councilor Mrs page sorry I wasn't quick
enough though to
page 8.7 8.1 could the officer please
give some more detail on this engagement
method with the residents and
stakeholders thank you
so I
um
sorry 8.7
oh sorry yep
yep sorry member um yeah so when we
first reported that we would be going to
members public once we've done a few
more reviews because there wasn't any
point at the start we will be putting
something in place hopefully we'll be
using not hopefully shouldn't say
hopefully we will be using something
called engagement HQ which is a product
that
um Luke and Kinsey from the digital team
is bringing into place which is a
consultant consultation process so that
we can engage in different methods with
the public
so we're looking at that and how that
will be and how that will work
thank you sorry that may be through
polls or through General questionnaires
and consultation
thank you does that answer your question
Council missing his page yeah I think so
yeah
thank you
um Greg just um in general regarding the
report
um while it's good to see um savings are
being made
um what is the impact with these savings
on our service delivery and how is this
being monitored
so the all service reviews do not seek
to have any negative impact in fact
they're there to create resiliency and
continuity and improve where we can in
the services that's what they were set
up to do so anything that would happen
in negative impact would be brought back
before members but that is not happening
because we're not setting that up to
happen
um
and Part B of the question apologies oh
has it been monitored so what we will be
doing is making sure that performance
measures are set up it's an i it has
been recently identified by the Auditors
who went through and said there's
actually nothing in the business case
that we've set up that identifies the
performance coming out the other side so
we are adding that to the business case
so we're making sure that that is
recorded and oversight on our part we're
making sure that it's now recorded so
we'll have performance measures to make
sure that whatever we say certainly
doesn't get any worse but hopefully
we'll see some improvement or at least
stay the same thank you um members any
other questions
I can see nobody indicating so remember
there are two recommendations set out at
page 8.1 of the report the first is that
the committee notes the progress of the
one team trans transformation program is
that noted members
and the second that the committee makes
any recommendations to the executive for
consideration there have been no further
recommendations made thank you very much
members
foreign
okay members we're moving swiftly on to
agenda item nine treasury management
annual review
um I will now invite the council's
interim director of resources Tim to
introduce the report again we have had
this report so Tim will keep this
succinct
thank you chair
um this report says how retrospective
look
at the council's treasury management
activities in 2223 because the council
has no borrowing the report focuses on
investments only the council held
substantial cash balances during the
year and sought to obtain a return on
those balances
the council was governed by the
principles of security liquidity and
yield when investing in that order
The increased interest rates during the
year enabled us to earn interest of 544
000 pounds last year compared to only
thirty thousand the year before
happy to answer any questions
thank you members
councilor Milne
uh yeah just one one question because
this is a retrospective look and it's
quite nice to see this income coming in
uh with the view so the fact that the
government is now pressuring the banks
to actually increase their returns as
part of their inflation uh controls uh
how do we look ahead on safe Investments
that are going to get us some more more
money from these uh these instant
accounts it's easy to change those
uh that's all there is really and what
sort of improvement do you think we
would get
in return
thanks Jay um yes we do have a variety
of different counterparties or
institutions banks that we can invest
with
um they are restrictive because of the
rules that we impose upon ourselves
um and it is important most important
that where we place the money is safe
nowhere is 100 always safe but they the
where we invest is very safe
it has to be
um so that's always going to be
important and the government
um government agencies operate schemes
which you can earn a return from as well
as from large Banks which are also
available and earn a competitive rates
at the map that you can get competitive
rates at the moment from those two
um so I don't have an issue with
um the government's
um
plans to impose more regulation or an
agenda regarding the major Banks having
an impact on our ability to earn a
decent return for as long as interest
rates are still relatively high and they
are our advisors are saying they
they were saying they're going to Peak
um by about now a few months ago and now
they're saying they're going to Peak
maybe towards the end of the year and it
might not even be till next year now so
which is good news for any
any Savor rather than our borrower at
the moment
does that answer your question
councilman
thank you members anybody else
indicating to speak
so members there is one recommendation
set out page 9.1 of the report to
recommend the contents of the report to
four counts or all those in favor can
you please raise your hand
remember that's unanimous
members now moving on to a gender item
10 the approval of the overview and
scrutiny committee's annual report
members do you have any questions on the
report
foreign
I see nobody indicating so members is
the report noted
thank members
a gender item 11 the key decisions
document you will have had that passed
out this evening the updated version
um members are there any questions on
the key decision document
I see nobody indicating members
thank you so moving forward a gender
item 12 hour work plan
members you've got the work plan there
in front of you
now if we look at the
um meeting in September
I aim to move that forward for members
to note
to the Wednesday the 13th of September
that will also allow the working group
set up following item seven
some time
to put together their report
but also then if you can turn to the
final page
we have got some items to be scheduled
onto our work plan
and I'm looking members to set up some
individual task and finish groups
now one will be the review of outside
bodies and external Partnerships
now this will only need two or three
members I'm quite happy to put myself
forward for that do I have another
member who would like to join that
working group counselor Paige and Milne
so for the review of the outside bodies
and external Partnerships that's myself
counselor Mrs page and councilor Mill
there is another working group
and it is to look at the work of the
Rangers
the highway ranges we've had a request
for
this committee to look and investigate
and review this service if it should be
continued budget implications for next
Municipal year cost of the council run
rate performance against budget
Etc do I have any members who would like
to put themselves forward for this work
thank you councilor Lamborn and
councilor sparing
and Council across thank you very much
Council of course sorry
so um I would like to ask those working
groups if they could Endeavor to bring
forward a report to that September
meeting I hope I'm not asking too much
from you but obviously with budget
implications we would like it sooner
than later and so we can make our
recommendations
so we have those three items for our
September meeting
we also have I believe already on there
a review of the parks for nature project
and I think if members are in agreement
that would make that quite a full agenda
with those items have I got your
agreement members with that one yeah
thank you
um I have worked out the pre-meet dates
which I will circulate to everyone over
the next few days I think that that will
work better for everyone if you've got
them in clear advance I may mean for a
week before our actual meeting and of
course ensuring that you've had the
papers in good time to read through them
for that pre-mate
are there any comments yes thank you
Council award
thank you chairman
um I noticed that
um on the reviews that have been carried
out
um the review should complete with
regard to planning and enforcement on
July the end of this month
um I would be very interested to hear
what has actually happened with
enforcement would that be possible to
ask that to come in on November where
you've got the space the 2nd of November
ah um you're talking about the first
item to be scheduled yes so you're
asking for that to come forward in
November yes yeah we can pop that down
for November thank you
any other members any questions or
comments
is that agreed their members at the
moment and then we can review the work
plan again at our next meeting
thank you very much members that
concludes our business for this evening
thank you for
um working so swiftly through the second
half of our meeting very appreciated